vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
l'amérique va-t-elle connaître ce soir
le nom de son prochain président plus de
48 heures après l'élection le
dépouillement se poursuit dans certains
états clés et le vent tourner en faveur
de joe biden après la géorgie le
candidat démocrate devant serait donald
trump en pennsylvanie le chef de la
maison blanche continue de dénoncer je
cite humble électorale un des
confirmands en france pas avant janvier
peut-être des sanctions pour les
entreprises qui n'auraient pas recours
au maximum de télétravail et des
protocoles sanitaires revue pour les
lycées
sur les principales déclarations
aujourd'hui de l'exécutif français alors
que l'europe est la région du monde avec
le plus grand nombre de contaminations
devant les états unis
les premiers transferts de malades du
grand test vers l'allemagne se
poursuivre
[Musique]
le début d'une tournée des pays
européens méditerranéens pour gérald
darmanin dans le cadre de la lutte
antiterroriste le ministre de
l'intérieur s'est rendu d'abord en
tunisie dira en algérie dimanche
moment d'émotion pour ce petit fils
d'algériens qui rendra hommage à son
grand père ancien tirailleur dans son
village natal
m
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france est la
une de l'actualité ce vendredi
l'amérique dans la tente du nom de son
futur président toujours 264 grands
électeurs pour joe biden et 214 pour
donald trump selon les médias américains
sachant qu'il en faut deux cent soixante
dix pour l'emporter
le dépouillement se poursuit dans cinq
états clés en arizona dans le nevada ou
alors ou encore en caroline du nord en
pennsylvanie selon les médias américain
joe biden passerait devant donald trump
dans le décompte des votes
s'il remporte cet état démocrate aura
suffisamment de grands électeurs pour
accéder à la maison blanche
et puis en géorgie le vote est très
serré l'état a déjà annoncé un
recomptage des voix
depuis plusieurs heures maintenant joe
biden lui se dit certain de son élection
qu'il qualifie d' imminente et pour
l'équipe de donald trump
je cite l'élection n'est pas fini on va
retrouver en direct de washington notre
envoyé spécial thomas bonnin bonsoir
thomas le suspense continue donc de
votre côté
les médias américains actualise assez
régulièrement ces dernières heures les
résultats dans des états tels que la
pennsylvanie où la géorgie dans ces deux
états il affirme que désormais je baille
donne est en tête une courte avance sur
donald trump par exemple en géorgie il
affirme que le démocrate et une avance
d'à peine mille voix sur son concurrent
c'est pour cette raison que l'état va
procéder à un recomptage des votes
écouter le secrétaire d'état de la
géorgie qui s'est exprimé il ya quelques
heures à 10 heures du matin il restait
un peu moins de 1500 voix a compté dans
les comtés de gwyneth floyd cherokee et
cob
en outre il reste 8890 bulletins de vote
militaires en suspens qui seront contées
s'ils parviennent avant la fermeture des
bureaux aujourd'hui à l'heure actuelle
les résultats en géorgie reste trop
serré pour pouvoir trancher alors que
nous nous rapprochons d'un décompte
final nous pouvons commencer à envisager
la prochaine étape avec une marge assez
fine il y aura un recomptage angers en
ce qui concerne les médias américains
estiment que baye donne est devant avec
désormais douze mille voix d'avancé une
bascule qui s'explique notamment par le
dépouillement tardive des bulletins par
correspondance ainsi que des votes par
anticipation notamment dans la ville de
philadelphie qui votent
traditionnellement démocrate dalle trump
conteste le dépouillement dans cette
ville qui la qualifie sur twitter il ya
quelques heures comme une ville qui je
cite à une histoire pour i concernant
l'intégrité des élections alors certains
médias affirment que si les résultats
dans ces deux états la pennsylvanie et
la géorgie était confirmée il pour
proclamer la victoire de joe biden car
il lui suffit un seul état une seule
victoire dans un de ces deux états lui
suffirait pour atteindre les 270
l'écueil des lecteurs on surveille aussi
les résultats dans le nevada où by donne
est également annoncée en tête
écoutez aussi nancy pelosi chef des
démocrates du congrès qui a donné une
conférence de presse il ya quelques
elle parle déjà de joe biden comme du
président élu ce matin il est clair que
l'équipe by john harris va gagner la
maison blanche
son élection est historique porté par le
plus grand scrutin de l'histoire de
notre pays
73 8 millions d'américains le plus grand
nombre de votes jamais enregistré par
aucune élection américaine dans
l'histoire
le président-élu byden devra mener un
mandat fort et il aura une chambre des
représentants à majorité démocrate
solide à ses côtés et puis cette
information importante joe biden va
s'exprimer ce soir ce sera certainement
aux alentours de 20h american on verra
si c'est pour proclamer sa victoire lors
de sa dernière prise de parole on se
rappelle joe biden avait s'était dit
confiant mais avait demandé à ses bas
ses soutiens d'être patient avant de
pouvoir annoncer sa victoire et puis de
son côté donc donald trump continue de
revendiquer lui aussi la victoire tout
en accusant certains de vouloir lui
voler l'élection là devait une
conférence de presse hier
mais allocution qui a été coupé en plein
direct par un certain nombre de médias
qui ont accusé le président de divulguer
de fausses informations de sur des
accusations de fraudes notamment va
suivre donc attentivement les prochaines
prises de parole notamment celle de joe
biden et puis on verra comment réagira
le locataire de la maison blanche au
discours de l'ancien vice président
merci thomas pour toutes ces précisions
thomas bonnin en direct de washington
la peine en pennsylvanie joe biden est
passée aujourd'hui devant donald trump
dans le décompte des voix un état clé
dans la course à la présidentielle
est ce qui explique notamment les
tensions autour du dépouillement envoyer
les explications de guy marosi des
électeurs rassemblés devant les bureaux
de vote de philadelphie en pennsylvanie
des pros trump des pro by day tous
réunis pour dénoncer le vol de
l'élection par le camp adverse avec des
slogans opposé stopper le décompte ou
compter chaque vote selon la couleur du
candidat supporter
nous avons une administration qui
annonce sans vergogne qu'elle va ignorer
les véritables résultats de cette
élection et essayer de voler l'élection
à celui qui je pense est le véritable
vainqueur est correct voilà c'est un
coup d'état
une trame fait un coup d'état pour voler
ces élections et ce est illégitime
ils ont arrêté les élections le soir du
scrutin pour pouvoir s'arrêter et aller
chercher des faux bulletins afin de
pouvoir gagner quand vous avez toutes
ces quantités de vote qui vont à des
gens dont on ne savait même pas s'il
devrait être acceptée vous ne savez pas
qui les remplit vous ne savez pas qui
les renvoie cela devient donc un
problème la pennsylvanie est en effet au
centre de toutes les attentions
comptant parmi les swing states ces
états pivots qui selon l'élection font
pencher la balance côté républicain ou
démocrate
la pennsylvanie a changé huit fois
d'allégeance au cours des 100 dernières
années elle a d'ailleurs contribué à la
victoire de donald trump en 2016 après
24 ans de fidélité au camp démocrate
c'est aussi le cinquième état le plus
pourvus en grands électeurs celui qui
remporte la pennsylvanie remporté 20 des
538 vote du collège électoral cib hayden
rafle son état natal à trump la victoire
lui serait assuré d'où les crispations
autour du scrutin à l'origine de ces
tensions le nombre de votes par
correspondances envoyées dans les
bureaux pennsylvanien des millions de
bulletins qu'il faut dépouiller
or ces votes par correspondance favorise
le candidat démocrate dont le score
augmente au fil des heures
donald trump lui préfère y voir une
fraude des accusations rejetées par
l'exécutif local c'est un cas où il
essaie de voler une élection il essaie
de truquer une élection au système de
vote et nos bases de données font en
sorte qu'aucun électeurs ne puissent
voter plus d'une fois moins des moines
vol et il ya littéralement un frein si
jamais quelqu'un essayait and cry
la bataille autour du scrutin en
pennsylvanie a d'ailleurs failli virer
au drame hier soir la police de
philadelphie a arrêté deux hommes qui
projetait de s'attaquer à l'un des
bureaux de vote de la ville
des tensions qui règnent au sein d'une
amérique plus que jamais divisée et le
dépouillement ne suscite pas détention
qu'en pennsylvanie l'arizona où la
géorgie sont également concernés la
géorgie où certains électeurs sont prêts
à défendre leur candidat les armes à la
main ils trichent clairement les
démocrates ont des morts qui votent pour
eux ils font cela à chaque fois cette
fois nous ne supporterons pas si vous
savez que quelque chose ne va pas le
verrons si vous sentez que sa vache
rejoignez votre milices locales les
résultats de l'élection sont donc
suspendus au dépouillement de quelques
dizaines de milliers de bulletins
ironie du sort le vainqueur en
pennsylvanie pourrait bien s'installer à
la maison blanche située à washington au
1600 pennsylvania avenue
et depuis plusieurs jours maintenant
donald trump se dit victime de fraude
électorale il multiplie les recours pour
tenter d'arrêter les votes
un discours qui trouve écho chez ses
partisans via notamment les réseaux
sociaux regarder ce que nous a compilé
pierre jan masaryk stop de style
depuis le 3 novembre le slogan déferle
sur les réseaux sociaux
et lors des rassemblements pro trump à
l'origine du phénomène les rumeurs de
fraudes du parti démocrate dans
l'élection propagée par le président
américain et son clan une théorie qui a
entraîné la création de ce top de style
une page facebook qui relaie ces
théories de tricherie incitant notamment
à manifester de manière parfois
violentes pour protester contre les
résultats électoraux 350 mille membres
auraient rejoint le groupe en 48 heures
ce jeudi
facebook a décidé de supprimer cette
page de son réseau en accord avec les
mesures exceptionnelles que nous prenons
durant cette période de fortes tensions
nous avons supprimé le groupe stop ce
style qui crée des événements réels
le groupe était organisée autour de la
délégitimation du processus électoral et
nous y avons constaté des appels à la
violence
inquiétant
la campagne stock de style a également
trouvé un forte échos sur twitter un
hashtag parmi d'autres slogans qui
remettent en cause les résultats de
l'élection
[Musique]
un point sur la situation sanitaire en
france à présent avec près de 3000
nouveaux malades hospitalisés ces
dernières 24 heures 85 % des lits en
réanimation qui seraient occupés un
deuxième épisode épidémique qualifiée de
brutale et qui se propage rapidement
selon jérôme salon le directeur général
de la santé mais pas de nouvelles
mesures de restriction annoncées pour
l'instant le ministre de la santé a
surtout appelé les français à respecter
le confinement en cours depuis une
semaine maintenant alors que le nombre
de personnes hospitalisées continue
d'augmenter l'ap-hp a décidé d'arrêter
temporairement l'accueil aux urgences de
l'hôtel dieu pour redéployer le
personnel médical dans d'autres
structures hospitalières
plusieurs dizaines de manifestants
soutenus par des élus de gauche se sont
réunis cet après midi devant l'hôpital
pour protester david khalifa sur place
c'est une consternation pour l'ensemble
des aides soignants de ce service des
urgences de l'hôtel dieu tout d'abord
avec ce chiffre plus de mille personnes
sont en réanimation en ile de france et
peut atteindre le pic de saturation des
hôpitaux franciliens un non-sens
sanitaires et la raison avancée à part
la paix hpc tout d'abord de redéployer
le personnel professionnel de ranimation
dans d'autres hôpitaux également de
créer des lits de réanimation dans un
hôpital voisin en l'occurrence l'hôpital
cochin
ce qui est contesté donc c est la
fermeture de services d'urgence car
automatiquement sa ferme des lits au
lieu de créer des lits qui existait bien
on en supprime à davantage la
justification avancée également par
l'ap-hp c'est le côté vétuste de
l'hôtel-dieu une justification
totalement insensé pour la plupart des
élus politiques venus soutenir ce
mouvement de contestation
elle est visitée
logo vous avez des locaux qui ont été
complètement refait à neuf un plateau
technique est tout à fait opérationnel
donc ça c'est une c'est un mensonge
éhonté vous aviez lors du premier
confinement martin hirsch avait y
compris dit qu'il y avait pas de de
fluides or il ya l'effet d'oxygène
totalement disponible dans cet hôpital
non pelées mensonges ça suffit on arrête
de casser l'hôpital public on n'accepte
pas la fermeture des urgences nous
venons pour visiter avec la direction
les locaux et pour prouver qu'ils ne
sont absolument pas vétuste et qu'ils
sont tout à fait opérationnel pour
recevoir des patients qui sont non pas
qu'ils n'ont pas obligatoirement besoin
de réanimation un moment donné où il
manque des lits on voit que c'est une
aberration parce qu'ils vont préférer
utiliser des transferts en tgv pour
changer des patients de région plutôt
que d'utiliser cet hôpital qui est prêt
à accueillir les patients
ce que dénonce également les élus c'est
un projet de privatisation à d'un tiers
de l'hôtel-dieu entre l'ap-hp et la
ville de paris la fois pour en faire des
logements étudiants mais aussi des
commerces à des start-up de santé et un
restaurant gastronomique malgré le
confinement une poignée d' aides
soignants et d'élus politiques sont
venus soutenir et protester contre la
fermeture du service des urgences de
l'hôtel-dieu la police a rapidement
opéré à des verbalisations et dispersé
le rassemblement pour faire respecter le
confinement mis en place par le
gouvernement et en seine-et-marne les
professeurs se sont rassemblés pour
exprimer leur colère contre le ministre
de l'éducation nationale il souhaite
dénoncer le manque de moyens dans leur
département lors de l'appel à manifester
il ya un mois mais après l annonce de la
mise en place d'un protocole sanitaire
renforcée dans les lycées avec davantage
de cours à distance
ils reprochent toujours le manque
d'anticipation et de discernement de
jean michel blanquer refasse est
deuxième ce deuxième épisode épidémique
le scandale des masques et demandent des
masques gratuits pour les élèves et les
enseignants écouté et on voulait se
rassembler aujourd'hui pour faire
entendre notre mécontentement face à un
protocole sanitaire qui link est
difficilement applicable
on en a assez d'entendre des choses
qu'on ne peut pas mettre en place
simplement dans son établissement je ne
sais pas si le ministère où les
représentants locaux viennent et savent
à quoi ressemble un établissement
scolaire
il ya des salles qu'on ne peut pas être
correctement il ya des cantines qu'on ne
peut pas on ne peut pas étendre les murs
il ya des cours de récréation qui sont
trop petites pour que les élèves
puissent respecter une distanciation
physique comme elle est recommandée et
on en a aussi à c'est du mépris du
ministre en ne cesse de faire remonter
depuis des années le fait qu'en fait on
n'a pas les moyens et là on en fait on
est de plus en plus dans l'urgence est
aujourd'hui on est près de craquer voilà
c'était ça qu'on voulait faire entendre
c'est qu'on va pas pouvoir tenir plus
longtemps dans cette situation sanitaire
vigipirate crise sociale on va pas
pouvoir tenir plus longtemps avec le peu
de moyens qu'on a
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
ce soir avec pierre prix auraient
secrétaire général à senez fsu de
toulouse
bonsoir pierre priolet merci beaucoup
d'être avec fonctionn'air telfrance
alors le ministre a dit qu'il pourrait y
avoir maintenant 50% de présentiel et
50% de cours à distance
est ce que vous êtes satisfait de cette
annonce mais écoutez d'abord cette
annonce elle est incomplète parce que le
ministre a parlé de la situation des
lycées il a oublié quand même la moitié
des élèves du second degré qui sont en
collège et pour lesquels les situations
bien son
et d'ailleurs quand je déteste quand
même très incomplète et puis surtout qui
une fois plus dans la précipitation
alors déploré le fait que ce ne soit pas
applicable au collège néanmoins dans les
lycées comment ça va se passer c'est
ainsi chaque chaque que nice et va
pouvoir décider de le faire ou pas c'est
un peu ce qu'on craint on pense qu'on
peut pas se payer le luxe de laisser les
établissements décider eux mêmes de ce
qu'il faut faire ou pas il me semble les
reportages entrer que la situation
sanitaire est très sérieuse et que donc
c'est toute la nation qui doit se
mobiliser
on ne peut pas demander d'un côté aux
personnes de rester chez elle de rester
continuer de respecter le confinement et
dans le même temps ne pas prendre toutes
les mesures qui s'imposent dans
l'éducation nationale qui scolarise
quand même et qui accueille 1
pratiquement un quart de la population
française donc ce qui se passe dans
l'éducation nationale ne doit pas être
indifférents à l'ensemble de la
population ce que vous demande était
repris au rêve ou c'est le même schéma
qu'en que lors du premier confinement
c'est-à-dire à distance à 100%
non absolument pas on a constaté au
printemps les dégâts que pouvaient
produire de l'enseignement à distance à
haute dose et exclusivement pour ce
qu'on demande nous c'est qu'on garde les
écoles et les collèges lycées ouverts le
plus longtemps possible mais ça
nécessite d'avoir des précautions de
prendre des précautions ça nécessite de
mettre les moyens nécessaires de
recruter les personnels qu'il faut pour
pouvoir assurer cet enseignement aux
côtés des élèves ce sera probablement un
peu dégradée mais ça sera toujours
nettement mieux que ce qu'on a fait au
printemps et c'est essentiel pour nos
adolescents aujourd'hui qui n'ont de
toute façon pas du tout envie de revivre
la situation du printemps et nous
n'avons pas envie de les laisser sur le
bord des routes
faire du 50 %
en présentiel et du 50% à distance est
ce que ça ne fait pas une une surcharge
de travail pour les professeurs ont
écouté il est clair que des professeurs
pourront pas assurer au même instant et
dans le nez dans à la fois la conduite
de la classe la préparation des cours et
d'enseignement à distance maintenant il
faut trouver quand même ou bien dire les
choses c'est une moins mauvaise solution
que le confinement total ou elf et enfin
que la fermeture des établissements
voilà c'est un on est en situation
d'urgence il faut accepter une certaine
dégradation de la qualité de
l'enseignement j'allais dire mais c'est
pour protéger l'ensemble de la
population est encore une fois en
concernant du présentiel
on limite quand même fortement les
effets pervers encore faut-il y mettre
les moyens
est-ce que je ça pourrait être une des
solutions parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
de retard lors du premier confinement
les élèves en difficulté avec des
beaucoup de mal à à suivre justement ces
cours à distance
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas priorisées
m les bons élèves entre guillemets à
distancer et les moins bons et en
présentiel sais c'est pas comme ça que
la question se pose parce que même des
élèves qui étaient de bons élèves ont
finalement décroché ou ce qu'ils ont
appris à distance en réalité ils ne
l'ont pas réellement appris tous les
collègues aujourd'hui on fait le constat
depuis la rentrée il ya des élèves qui
ont complètement décrochés donc il ne
répondait plus qu'on avait pu dont on
n'avait plus de nouvelles de cela c'est
évidemment une catastrophe mais même les
élèves qui ont été assidus en réalité
n'assimile pas les connaissances de la
même manière que dans la classe et donc
mais le doivent aussi être scolarisés
dans leur intérêt les épreuves communes
du nouveau bac sont annulés a annoncé
également jean michel blanquer
c'est une bonne mesure selon vous c'est
parce qu'on attendait parce que
jean-michel dans le coeur est
opportuniste et profite de la crise
sanitaire pour finir de tuer le
baccalauréat est le cadrage national et
la valeur du diplôme
nous ce qu'on demandait c'était
simplement un report des épreuves au
mois de juin de manière à ce que
on évalue les élèves dans de bonnes
conditions la renvoyer le contrôle
continu ça veut dire très clairement
qu'on pousse encore plus loin la logique
du baccalauréat maison et donc on sait
très bien que l'on dilue la valeur de
music hall les épreuves d'autres
épreuves celle de mars par contre serait
maintenue avec une session de rattrapage
en juin
oui en réalité ce que propose deux
ministres se sont des sujets à géométrie
variable donc là aussi c'est un coup
porté au diplôme national à l'occasion
de la crise sanitaire donc qu'il faille
décalé ces épreuves au mois de juin ça
c'est une certitude
kifa éventuellement définir des
aménagements de programme ils demandent
aussi mais s'en remettre à des solutions
qui sont des bricolages locaux où l'on
laisse le choix aux élèves de choisir un
sujet plutôt qu'un autre c'est bien
remettre en cause le cadre national du
diplôme on déplore quand même que le
ministre appelle trick sanitaire en soit
encore à essayer de d'imposer sa réforme
du lycée est allé plus loin dans sa
logique que pensez vous du fait de
tester justement dans les collèges et
les lycées est ce que c'est le cas
d'ailleurs dans certains lycées
est ce que ce serait efficace selon vous
moi je suis pas épidémiologie je suis
pas en capacité de dire ce qu'il faut
faire d'un point de vue sanitaire par
contre ce que je peux dire c'est qu'on
connaît quand même très mal la
circulation du virus dans les
établissements l'objet le 6 circulent
c'est une certitude mais aujourd'hui les
études sont pas tout à fait concluante
au plan scientifique donc qu'on regarde
ce qui se passe réellement dans les
établissements qu'on sorte du déni
concernant la circulation du virus dans
des établissements scolaires c'est
plutôt une bonne chose
après je ne suis ni médecin ni galeriste
pour juger de la pertinence de la mesure
au plan médical et parce que le problème
c'est qu'on ne connaît pas véritablement
si le virus contamine beaucoup
effectivement dans les lycées ou les
collèges
est-ce que vous maintenez dernière
question l'appel à manifester mardi oui
pour la raison simple que j'ai exposé au
début c'est à l'école et jeu n'étant pas
concernés et nous avons des collèges
dans les effectifs sont bien supérieurs
à ceux des lycées nous en avons dans
notre académie on a des collèges amis de
sang ou me sens réel donc faire cette
distinction au motif que
les élèves en moins de 14 ans au coût de
14 ans ça n'a pas de sens en réalité
donc mon demande l'extension du
dispositif à l'ensemble des lycées parce
que pour l'instant ce n'est qu'une
possibilité offerte ce n'est pas une
obligation mais surtout on met également
la mesure en place dans les collèges
merci beaucoup pierre priolet d'avoir
répondu ce soir à nos questions sur rt
france le début d'une tournée des pays
medef méditerranéen pour gérald darmanin
dans le cadre de la lutte antiterroriste
le ministre de l'intérieur qui s'est
rendu aujourd'hui en tunisie il sera en
algérie dimanche ce sera pour lui un
moment d'émotion puisqu'il est petit
fils d'algériens et qu'il rendra hommage
à son grand père un ancien tirailleur
dans son village natal
voyez à présent la déclaration à tunis
du ministre de l'intérieur cet après
midi nous combattons ensemble
évidemment ce qui a déjà très largement
frappé notre pays à plusieurs reprises
et la france était à vos côtés qui a
frappé les pays
évidemment concernées en europe la
france bien sûr l'autriche
il n'y a pas si longtemps qui est une
idéologie que les français et surtout
pas moi qui suis petit fils d'immigré de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée et je
sais d'où je viens
ne confonde en aucun cas avec la grande
religion musulmane fait de tolérance et
bien sûr nous considérons que cette
idéologie n'a rien à voir avec les
religions comme vous l'avez
extrêmement bien dit mais cette
idéologie elle tue et cette idéologie
nous devons la combattre et je vous
remercie monsieur ministre après les
changes long que nous avons eue de
pouvoir continuer à faire ce travail
pour pouvoir échanger nos informations
et lutter contre ceux qui veulent mettre
à bas notre amitié et la relation
fraternelle entre nos peuples en russie
à présent alexeï navalni n'a pas été
empoisonné c'est ce qu'affirme la police
russe suite à une enquête de plusieurs
semaines le temps politique avait fait
un malaise souvenez vous fin août avant
de tomber dans le coma et d'être soignés
en allemagne et selon le rapport établi
par les médecins russes donc alexeï
navalni souffrirait d'une pancréatite et
de divers complications voyez les
détails avec notre correspondante à
moscou
verhaeghe hoffman plus de 200 personnes
interrogées plus de 60 expertise
judiciaire et 542 objets saisis aps le
ministère russe de l'intérieur affirme
que ce ne serait pas une substance
toxique qui serait à l'origine du
malaise d'alexis navale et les pousses
de navalni à informer les médecins que
son mari avait restreint son
alimentation est que pendant trois à
cinq jours il avait souffert d'une
sensation de malaise après les repas ces
prises de repas étant irrégulière son
épouse a également supposer que le
malaise pourrait avoir été provoqué par
un régime alimentaire du patient visant
à perdre du poids
après des études chimiques et
toxicologique répéter les médecins ont
établi le diagnostic final suivant
troubles du métabolisme des glucides
procréative chronique avait dit ce
fonctionnement des glandes exocrines
airs endocrine puis complications
le ministère allemand de la justice
affirme que la russie n'a pas fourni
toutes les informations nécessaires qui
concerne l'incident la russie rétorque
27 août au 28 septembre
le parquet général de russie à 34
demande d'être judiciaire dans le cadre
de l' enquête sur l'incident à bord de
l'avion reliant tomsk amos pizza 30
octobre nous avons reçu la réponse des
autorités allemandes compétentes
contenant des demandes d'informations
supplémentaires sur l' enquête en cours
ladite réponse ne contient aucune
explication de faux sur les questions
posées par la russie
on regarde cette réponse constatons que
jusqu'à présent nos demandes n'ont pas
été satisfaites
en fait ce retard empêche les autorités
compétentes de la fédération de russie
de faire toute la lumière sur les
circonstances de l'incident
le manque de coopération de berlin a
aussi été dénoncé par la porte parole de
la diplomatie russe mali hasard à wall
street c'est fargo
le ministère fédéral allemand de la
justice
une annonce absolument rien de nouveau
votre vie il ne fait qu'à dresser des
contres demande tout en confirmant que
les autorités à berlin refuse de fournir
des preuves matérielles de
l'empoisonnement de navettes par la
fameuse substance no big shot cher tout
comme ces tests biologiques et les
résultats des examens que ça dans ce
contexte nous tenons aussi à rappeler
que précédemment
après une demande de berlin toutes les
informations essentielles ont été
supprimées du rapport de l'organisation
pour l'interdiction des armes chimiques
sur la fourniture d'une assistance
technique à l'allemagne se sont jadis de
voix des questions tout à fait justifiée
se pose et nous les avons formulé à
plusieurs reprises que cachent nos
collègues allemands
quels sont les faits qu'ils ne veulent
pas rendre public comptera guettait et à
bonal aux douaniers chiwa agnetha wyatt
moscow espère qu'en fin de compte berlin
remplira ses obligations juridiques
internationales découlant de la
convention européenne d'entraidé
judiciaire en matière pénale la
diplomatie russe espère aussi que le
gouvernement d'angela merkel
s'abstiendra de toute politisation
artificielle de la situation qui nuit
sérieusement aux relations russo
allemandes et c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de votre fidélité on se retrouve
dans 30 minutes rester avec nous
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
accepter une volonté collecte